on this week's show what is article 4 in
the news dramatic changes in capital
gains tax could have a massive impact on
the property market and we're going to
be answering all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost the leads I'm Alistair
Cunningham and welcome to this week's
property investors podcast into it
yo good week yeah it's been cool very
busy so last few weeks I've been in
London constantly because we've been out
looking for offices as you as you're
well aware I am aware looking for new
offices because we are relocating and
drumroll we have found some officers
tell us about it
they are right bangin city centre on
Baker Street and there are really nice
offices next to sure next all Sherlock
Holmes it's really exciting times for
the company because the company is just
growing exponentially I suppose it kind
of makes you know the amount of events
we're now doing down in London it kind
of makes sense to move down there
doesn't it hundred percent one hundred
you chosen an area that you're gonna be
living in we've not yeah I'm looking at
a lot of apartments tomorrow and me to
Vale in where medieval of those it's
near Lord's Cricket Ground so it's not
it's not too far you going out tomorrow
yeah I'm going out tomorrow oh yeah yeah
how are you getting there you're a dick
driving you're a dick
okay so yeah driving down could your
banners with you so and we even don't
London for mmm
I'm looking at a school Oh Beckett field
good it's good yeah no it's so important
isn't to the school yeah well it's quite
it's just on the edge but it means I can
get into into into linear Matt 23 makes
it was actually hard for Chow
Buckinghamshire okay I knew it wasn't
London I thought it was near him oh but
him was on the board rockin I'm sure
it's on it's on the border
but not it's pretty cool so it's goodie
are you excited for the move to London
do you think it's going to do the
business world yeah because it's queer
often to invest quite a bit of money in
there yeah in the move because it's not
it's not cheap but I think the growth of
the business is gonna be ridiculous yeah
yeah no I'm really excited is it's it's
the capital city isn't it it's the main
place where everything's happening so
it's going to be that we're gonna have
we're going to be having an event in
London every single week yeah
will it be a crash course a fulfillment
event anything but there's gonna be
something happening within our company
every single week in London so it makes
sense to be there yeah I agree I agree
it's gonna be I'm looking forward to it
in the areas lovely beautiful and ya
know rig site all right so let's let's
get cracking into article four then yeah
so do you want to kind of give us an
overview of well first of all why why
does article four exist what is article
four right okay so - in a nutshell yeah
article four is a boundary or an area
which the local authority have enforced
to stop you converting a standard house
standard resi
residential house into a house of
multiplication orkap Asian yeah
supposedly basically you can still do it
but you have to get planning permission
whereas before I walk him along you
could literally take a house you could
make it into a hitch or more without
planning up to five bedrooms so you
could do like a for bed and quite easily
five and six beds you had to get
planning you ever get a license you have
to get a license yes or a license um but
no but a lot it but licenses are pretty
easy to get online
they are licenses are easy to get but
now you need planning as well you don't
just need a license if it's now let's go
for is it hard before you have to you
have to go to a plan an application and
then you have to apply for the license
now realistically it's quite hard to get
isn't it yeah because the reason they've
brought article 4 in because they don't
want any more age amounts to stop
saturation yeah and because what was
happening like in Liverpool particular
the streets that are just full of
Hitcher moors and generally HMOs do
cause a little bit of disturbance so if
you've got like lots of hitch or moors
with they should see a house a 5-bit hm
all you've got five different tenants
five different standards five different
ways of living five different cars
five different this and it can cause a
little bit of disturbance to the area in
the street so if you've got a lot of
hitch more than one Street perhaps it's
not the I particularly I probably want
to live them well suppose in a way check
let's say you've got a straight where
all the houses are worth yep I don't
know three hundred thousand pound down
the straight through in two thousand man
house attracts a certain type of person
yes if you'll turn that those into fire
bed HMOs and there's lots of them
suddenly your change in the dynamic I
suppose of the of the straight absol and
it will have an R I think if you've got
a Street full of hits was it might have
a negative impact on the the value of
the properties if you've got like a
really nice residential let's just say
like for instance in in Hull there's a
street where there's a really nice large
Victorian houses they're huge and know
what X amount I don't know the exact
figure but they're worth X amount of
money but they're very nice but there's
also over the last four five years been
a lot HMOs being brought up there
because they're huge houses yeah I can
only smagin if I lived there I'll be a
little bit disappointed they always hate
you malls are coming to the area
and suddenly I think the house prices
might dip a little bit mmm so I think
art was a brilliant thing that well
that's one advantage to it the other
advantage is let's say you've got HMO in
that area in Hull and you're renting it
out nicely but then suddenly every
single house in the street becomes a HMO
something there's massively more
competition and you do get areas I mean
this happens for a time Wolverhampton
they obviously brought in but you get
areas where there's just so many rooms
about yeah available that used to mean
surrender from many rooms out do you
know it's I know are an investor who who
literally in this space of two months
completed on five properties in one
particular town all them HMOs and within
it within this so that they all
completely run the same short time he
had all the conversions done at the same
sort of time and then suddenly he's got
five five bedroom HMOs going to market
all at the same time so we've got twenty
five rooms suddenly hit in a town mm-hmm
didn't work because they filled a little
bit up so you got like an odd tenant
here
and everywhere but because there's such
an influx of her rooms to an area takes
longer to fit it's longer to fill it
takes everything but he sort of rushed
out and just went out and got them and I
know he was great at it because he then
tried to sell some of them so I think
and that's what article 4 is they have
to stop was to stop not not it's not to
stop their investor losing money it's to
stop their influx of a charm or
properties in a specific area without
having planning permission
I think it's brilliant because like what
happens at like Wolverhampton yeah
article 4 came in September 2017 yeah
yeah sure was back then so what happened
to house prices they skyrocketed but you
see what's happening in Wolverhampton in
the Midlands with house prices there
were like two three four years ago you
could get like a three bed Terrace for
the 80 grand
now you're talking over one 120 130 for
the same house it's now being converted
to hate Jamal and I know some of Samuels
properties have gone up drastically in
value because they weren't in an artic
for them now in Arctic four and he's got
grandfather rights and you had one of
those HMOs so it just protects the area
doesn't it yeah overall it's pretty much
a good thing yeah a lot of investors
look at it as a pain because they're
trying to buy a hey choke it down an
article for ah but it's actually you
know I don't see it as a pin I see it as
the they're regulating it I'm a
responsible landlord you responsible
landlord what have you got to worry
about
they're protecting the area they're
protecting the existing landlords that
protects in tenants the tenants and the
protect in the neighborhood yeah from
just there was a point where there was
so many people just buying HMOs and just
doing half-assed conversions on them now
at least if they've got to go through
planning and they've got to go through
licensing at least as regulation in
place in this this procedures in place
and this the standard immunity standards
in place and they're being enforced as
well which is which is good so let's say
them someone watching this show is a an
investor you know wanting to buy a HMO
how can they use article 4 for their
advantage by somewhere where article 4
is coming prime example Doncaster
October October this year to you you
ain't got long you
I ain't got long at all October 20 1912
or 2019 article 4 has been enforced in
Doncaster so it's been it's been ruled
out at the minute it doesn't exist it's
been ruled out in October 2019 so I've
had a lot of the best has been buying
buying in Doncaster over the last year
and what it might take a little bit of
time for it to happen ok but what's
going to happen is the house prices are
gonna go up the demand is going to
increase but the supply is not going to
go up so over time there's going to be
more hitch there's going to be more
demand for hate jamaal's because of
what's happening in the area with
regards to industry and all that stuff
but because there's no more supply
getting made because they're regulated
it and they've restricted it what's
gonna happen to room prices room places
are gonna go up values are gonna go up
well if everything's are gonna fill
anything the supply will get less
because over time there were people look
buyer seller hatred someone turns it
back into a family home yeah absolutely
over time I'd probably get less so look
for that here's the question this is a
question that I asked quite a lot and to
be honest it's actually a bit of a pain
how do you find out bless you okay that
was a comments laughs knees sorry excuse
me guys let's go come on cut and do that
again no ok I'm glad that you fancy so
follow us so how do you find out with an
area that is article for obviously you
know you we know from experience quite a
few areas but yeah like for example this
place like Wolverhampton is pretty much
a blanket article for you know
everywhere it's places like Birmingham
Walsall they've got tiny bits I can't
talk it max I'm gonna sneeze okay easy
right okay go on what is it how'd you
find out the faint veneer was Arctic for
mmm-hmm well this is the simplest way is
to ring the local authority because or
ring them and ask them that's the
easiest way or go on the website most
local authorities that have article half
of a designated part of the website
which is dictators in designated for
HMOs and it would normally have a HM or
map
they're of the article for boundary yeah
whole cities council has everywhere
everywhere I know that as a chart for
has you can only download that soul
actually with a map that will show you
where everything don't you find they're
quite hard to read they aren't terribly
hard to read because it's like they've
taken out a map and just drawn a big
black line rounders yeah that lead the
road names but it's just like red yeah
it's a bit of an especially it's like
bought the one located sort of
borderline cuz it cuts through straight
from literally can be the odd side of
the street is hard to go for the other
side's no it really can be and and also
like it can be we are like in Hull for
instance I forget the name in the world
but there's a massive me and we'll go
into whole article for goes up and in
goes up that way so that if you've got
house they are you okay it's that
society but that the wrong side of the
cross in your in and but just easiest
way Luke bring up the heat you're more
officer that's the worst cut you can
ring them up Agana really it's the
quickest way they're very helpful
whenever I spoke to any Hitcher more
Department a council that they're so
helpful because they want you to do it
right they want they want it done right
they don't want it done half-assed so
ring them up and ask them second way
would be jump on the council's website
and download the map and check on on a
map third way would be just google it
like is whole covered by article for and
it will tell you get me brilliant if
there was a website which just had yeah
a map of all the laws before he put a
dressing we go yes or no yeah because I
mean somebody's got created and then
somebody's got to get paid for it and
always gonna pay for other because most
will want stuff for free who don't want
to pay for things so that's really
nobody's gonna create it for free so I
you tempted me now to create it me free
if it wasn't so much work logistics to
do that and then everyone to see what
can happen for free yeah you can have it
maybe saw maybe someone this is just
shows gonna go and do it you know I
suppose leave a problem is it
consistently change it does it's always
not met Q updated but another way is to
speak to other investors in area but
yeah there's very is
easy to find though yeah it's pretty
easy just basically she's gone google it
and find it out all right so long story
short they're asking for its good thing
I think so if you're looking at buying
HMOs for you first of all check the
area's not article for look for areas
that article four is coming in yeah and
then just be aware that article four
really is there to protect the area and
also to protect you if you're buying a
house there you want the area protected
don't you you want to be a nice decent
area you don't want to so really overall
it's a good thing and the biggest tip
like you said look space like Doncaster
places where it's coming in by now there
is a small danger with that yeah
Oh long term it's good but in more of a
handsome costly we weren't quite a lot
around Wolverhampton what I found was in
the build up like economy because it
September came in it came it was
September 2017 it was enforced so around
sort of like July August time loads of
hate emails started coming up because
everyone was buying trying to get them
ready so for the for a couple of months
around that sort of time it was like
really hard to fill rooms and then it
settled down and now it's good so it's a
good time to buy but just be aware yeah
for a few months you might struggle to
win them and one thing to be aware of
don't think all right okay so let's just
say Doncaster article four comes in on I
think October the 1st 2019 but if you
buy a house in September 2019 and it
comes they should sake completes in
September 2019
yeah you've bought it before out for
comes in but you've got to have compared
to dit you've got to have all the work
done and and it been signed off or it be
you've got that proof that you've had
fired or and you've got to have an est
contract in there depends on the council
doesn't it it does hampton council they
were sort of saying you need to prove
you exactly but other councils are just
like no just prove you've had fire doors
fitted yeah again speak to the local
authority so don't just assume you can
buy a property in the month before it
comes in and you're automatically get
grandpa rights because your intention
was to make a HM all you have to base to
be a check it needs to be a hitch em all
and grandfather rights for anyone
doesn't know what that is
grandfather rights are where you've had
an existing HM or in an non article four
area
article for has come in you get
automatic grandfather rights which means
that you can carry on running his head
yeah so article 4 comes in it basically
says from now on you can't do it but
from before you can yeah before you can
however I don't think just because
you've got one that's been in there that
you you you've got to stick to the law
you've got to stick to immunity Sanders
you've got to sit pH more guidelines so
you can't just have a complete dive
about IHM all and then just think no
that's all I've got article for
grandfather rights no you still have to
apply them adhere to the laws and the
regulations yeah make some irresponsible
landlord guides we will right it's now
time for this
[Music]
okay in the news this week we're looking
at a dramatic change in capital gains
tax which could have an impact on the
property market would you like me to
read some of the artifacts sure - and
this listen okay so this is on the
property industry I second homeowners
landlords and property investors are
warned of a dramatic change to the
current capital gains tax so basically
while the new rules
there anyone selling a property after
the sixth of April 2020
okay feel a little bit happier where
capital gains taxes Joo will have to pay
the tax on any gain within 30 days of
completion at the moment the deadline is
January 31st following the end of the
year and was so was made so they have to
pay the tax a lot sooner no well 30 days
potentially well let's say we what you
bought a property in January yeah you
wouldn't have to pay it until the
following January no you've got no you
got to pay 30 days later yep yep so this
will affect both let investors and
owners of holiday homes plus others you
may have find themselves as an
accidental owner of a second property
legal tax specialist in roids with the
Kings private wealth team is urging
owners of more than one property to
carefully consider the impact this might
have he said the change could mean that
sellers have to get funds in place to
cover the capital gains tax liability
before the sales completed as 30 days is
not very long at all
this could be a particular issue where a
lot where there are large historic gains
landlords of essence second home owners
thinking of selling one or more property
next couple of years a well advised to
get professional invite at an early
stage to make sure they understand and
can meet their liabilities again it's
just the council having a lower stick to
be as worth isn't it it's not the
council the government it's not a lot of
stick for the government to smack as
well just something to be aware of
really when you especially for a larger
you know a lot larger houses builders to
be aware when you're selling it in many
ways it makes no difference in many ways
because you're still paying the same
Matt attack yeah no but if you're
I get like they said that that advice
was to get your funds in place before
you sell it that might not be possible
may not be possible yeah and people
might need that say take with them PYD
tax so that you do your corporation tax
your business you UN comes today you've
got a period of time to get it to get
taxed to sort it out and get it ready
but no it's just it to me at screams
desperation from the government they're
trying to get as much money in this
possible quick way mm-hmm so they can
spend it on holidays and and ironically
second homes are there in there spend it
on second homes spend it on putting us
in billions of pounds worth of debts and
brexit negotiations and all that sort of
chance but yeah has to affect you or not
but there you go that was your news very
interesting now time for this okay so
time for questions answers first
question coming in from alexander
Filimonov how do you tell a good
solicitor from a bad solicitor how do
you is this a good jewel it does sound
like a joke I'm sure this is line but it
does really sound like a joke doesn't it
I reckon if I Google he'll come up with
it with an answer for that
a good system as Lister will I find
solicitors have two speeds mm-hmm slow
and stop yeah so you continue having to
chase them all especially particular
very slow to them it's not urgent but do
you know what it's like when you're
buying a property right oh you want them
to do is just get that pull the finger
out and get home with it because you
know in the states when you're buying a
house it can be completed it can be
completed and make three weeks it's so
quick and here it just seems everything
takes so goddamn long three four months
is not uncommon I think it depends what
you want it for say I know I know
solicitors who are really really good
when it comes to the techie stuff yeah
but they're slow for normal stuff I
think perhaps what it is is they're
waiting there's there's too many people
involved so the
there's all different parties involved
so you got the the Sailor the back the
the Sailor the buyer the buyer solicit
as the sales list or the Sailor who's
got sent documents the BIOS got some
documents a state agent there's too many
people involved in it and if one
person's like oh yeah I'll do that
tomorrow it just everything just drags
on or not and I think another thing is
generally people that ask that question
are people that are looking for a cheap
solicitor they're looking for the
cheapest out there and I mean I've
always been taught about you pay cheaply
pay twice with everything so I think if
you're gonna go for professional
services to me cost wouldn't even come
into it if you want a speedy a speedy
set you can listen there's a thing and
now you can have it cheap but it won't
be quick you can have it quick but it
won't be cheap do not I mean mmm
spares the money that's the reason
there's another one becoming what it was
is it good yeah you can have a good one
be cheap or something good and quick
yeah but then it won't be I said you can
pick two of them then yeah yeah
what do you want do you want it good and
quick what do you want yeah and good and
quick but it won't be cheap cheap and
quick but it won't be good yeah good and
quick but it won't be cheap yeah it's
just one of these things I see on like
the problem basis with Simon's Facebook
group all the time people posting oh I'm
looking for I'm looking for a cheap
salata I would say go on go on a
recommendation and and and and you you
often get a good idea of how they deal
with you in the very very early stages
about whether they're gonna be speedy or
not for just a normal buying a house any
see any property sister will do it more
complicated where you're spending a lot
of money then you might want to go
someone bit more specialist who they
might be able to save you money on you
know some Jude and I would ask ask the
solicitor when you first instruct them
look how long you expect an S to take
have you got the capacity to deal with
this job if you haven't then fine tell
me just be honest with me now because I
don't want to pay like for instance my
brothers but I'm in the middle of
sorting out commercial lease on a
property and it's just a lease on a
property but he's got a solicitor to go
through all the paperwork so far has
taken two months hmm two months it's
ridiculous now he's likely wouldn't be
losing
properly because the solicitors are
taking so long you can't and he's paid
he's paid half the fee up front and half
on completion and it's just ridiculous
so I would have said to begin with look
I need this done honey it's done in four
weeks time can you do it if you can't do
it I'm not gonna use you if you can do
it I'll pay whatever you're asking I'll
pay the going rate so just don't be
don't be I'm scared to pay the money and
and don't try and scrimp on but to
basically just be very clear about what
you want and just have a frank
conversation and find out if they very
much yeah all right so how's your
question aiexander next how can you go
direct to vendor on properties that are
on Rightmove to do a lease option
agreement deal that's from mile s1 g1
hopefully not his real name well look we
teach about sort of trying to do things
ethically so I would there's many many
ways to do it a little tip is try and
book viewings and evening so most of the
agents don't walk past 4:30 you don't do
viewings past 4:30 I mean not often I've
had a few at 6 but like Jim Jim really
Bentley living in London in London yeah
but not not where we are looking for
investment properties up north north
they probably don't do past like 2:00
p.m. be careful right ok so I normally
try and boot viewings if I'm wanting to
do if I wanted a specific thing with a
property or a lease option or whatever I
would book a viewing later an evening
and so when you're speaking to us they
didn't just say um look I'm a neighbor
tomorrow the only time I can view is an
evening
can the with a vendor let me come and
view round it with with the vendor for
me Roland and nine times out of 10 they
will because they want to sell the house
I know a little tip I would do is you
should have some business cards made up
now get them meet up magnetic get
magnetic business cards like oh this is
a new little magnetic business cards
what's to get on the fridge and when
you're in a house even if even if it's
during the day okay and you're in a
house in a state agents showing you
around just stick on the fridge when
estate agents not
can and just put like so if you
something we will buy your house or
something at that do you want to sell
your house quickly we're decided I would
be like freaked out
yeah but just bang on the first girl way
out cause one person will one person
will how did you how did they even get
there oh yeah
did you break in to put it on my
obviously just explain the more I was on
a viewing and I wanted to offer you a
better do an estate agent would offer
you I said if it gets one form quarters
Wharf the 19 the nine pound it'll cost
you for like five hundred magnetic
business cards it's just not it's just
another little tape man you don't have
to do it you do have to do it if you do
that and it works please please let me
know let me know yeah if you get abuse
mean that's funny that's always funny
and but it's just look you've gotta get
creative if you want to get direct to
vendor leads through a state agency I'll
get creative guys it's very creative
yeah I think so and other ways you get
my business cards yeah I've got my mate
I don't have a mouse I don't do it
anymore but I used to do and if I start
on the fridge yes did you ever have a
call do you know what's even more fun
about it trying to do it when the state
agent doesn't catch you because you're
trying to do it sneakily bet you could
do you have to palm it and whack it on
this is a nice fridge cool right we do
one more from Instagram yeah and I've
got loads on here okay will do will do
why I'm on Facebook yeah okay the best
way to set up your team sourcing area
just letting agents construction of
solicitors etc from Phil then it may far
Phil then it may fall yep so we're
looking at setting up our team I believe
so yes again it comes down to people and
it comes down to getting episode episode
I tell you what Phil we're not gonna
answer you question we'll do a podcast
about how to help our team see you've
created a whole new episode Phil well
done the next episode we're going to
discuss that
because that it's not a two-minute
conversation we could talk for ages
about that our brilliant they go Phil
Thank You Phil all credit Phil you are
gonna have to watch next we'd say floor
sorry Phil well that's maybe maybe he
missed this one mm-hmm
who knows anyway Thank You Phil Linnet
or May right okay I've got some
questions go on last one um Brad Hart
do you remember this guy yeah he's every
time I Harry I think Bret Hart Bret Hart
that Bret the Hitman Hart Brad the
Hitman Hart
yeah so Brad was the young lad that came
to the podcast live in London he's like
16 17 years old that you gave her a
round of applause to yeah I'll tell you
why because he's 16 17 he was 16 he just
turned 65 no because it's not North oh
that's what no but he made the effort to
come for this for the first time in
London so it's because he let us say
entrapped him for coming to London
listen is it for a 60 no it's a big
thing me he got on a train come all the
way to London split the hotel stayed in
a hotel on his own in the middle of
London came to the podcast live it's a
big thing for a 16 year old to do man
give him back credit I did good what but
yeah well I'm right you wrote on Brad so
if you only had 1,000 pounds what would
you do well if you gave me in Russell
500 pound each will tell you no I'm
kidding and listen thousand pound what
would you do a thousand yeah hold on
what's the situation me now what to do
with it he wants to get Brad wants to
get into property
he's young lad it's not how I do that
it's what what would Brad stuck yeah
it'd blow as well
Brad we're doing Brad with what would
Brad do to get involved in props so what
he's got nothing and he just closed him
back but nothing he give him a grand
financial freedom challenge but you
started the ground yeah the problem
you've got is it's not a lot um I think
my thousand ponies basically didn't know
many down deals
yeah he's got to get out there and he's
to educate and he's got I would say I
would say use that for expenses to
getting about and meeting people and
like travel and going to go into don't
go into networking events and go into
areas meeting agents and like you you'll
find that thousand-pound but probably
not last that long and you take you to a
casino yeah
now when he would yes if we start if we
did the finance room challenge now we
had a grand age I know that your first
place you'd go is the casino yeah triple
up and then go and use it that's thing I
would do it anyway we saw a film that
you should do that very happy to the
world make you films and pans they won't
let you film in a casino oh you could do
your sleight of hand
Nick with the lights behind you anyway
them are so thousand-pound listen man I
would get out there and get into areas
and use I would use it for expenses and
education buying lots of books read do
you know that the most successful CEOs
of in the world read one book a week one
a week hmm that's more than I do to a
month yeah said successful ah successful
kiddin he's very successful
but listen and I would get out there
educate get some get lots of books on
the about and get out meeting people go
to as many free events as possible so
come to the crash courses just say one
say and Steve get into the habit of
saving so that photos I'm cloud well
hold on why don't we like that
thousand-pound Brad if you have you been
to the crash course if you have Samuel
covers a t harv a car money jars you
should put that into the money jars
oh yeah I'll just save it but it yeah
yeah okay I hope you're a little bit
clearer on that you probably aren't but
I would save it and base they would
invest more I try and try get more or
get listen if you know me down deal then
you're looking at Renteria lease option
agreement even though thousand plans not
reeling off a lease option probably is
for a renter and a renter ed maybe but
you've got to find there you've got
thing got up here fast
ran and if you didn't got a thousand
pound I would say don't do it too risky
on because you want at least three or
four months rent and available in the
bank to wait for that that period of
time so just keep learning and saving
key I would keep that up saving get out
there read your books get to networking
events get meeting people get meeting
agents go and stand in front of an agent
and tell them look you're 16 you're
desperate to get in property ensuring
that you actually want this you'll find
the agents will help you because you're
eager and your your em you're putting
yourself out there they've got time for
one more
Guam okay and this is from Gulf share
ago gov gov and hi guys I go what's your
opinion on outsourcing tasks when you
first starting out such as building your
website versus doing it yourself I would
I would do it as long as you've got but
if you've got no money at all then
obviously you can't but oh yeah I would
do because you can get it's good it's
probably better than if you do yourself
yeah a hundred percent we talk all the
time about why why do a ten pound an
hour job when you you can add fact panda
nowhere else will and what pens and oils
were whatever and I personally with
outsource as much as possible as long as
you've got the budget to do so because I
like I'm rubbish at creating websites so
I got something to do it for me because
I just can't do it it's not gonna be as
efficient and is it's not gonna work as
well but I mean we outsource a lot done
way like better sourced is a lot of it's
been outsourced so that it's systemized
situation when you first start a
business you'll probably do everything
yeah to begin with because you've got
you've got no money or whatever but but
if I was talking business now obviously
I wouldn't do that when you first get in
started you have to be prepared to do
everything and pull your shoes up but
shoes up they wouldn't even work you
just be like the complete opposite of
outsourcing into classes fighting
against yourself into your shoes over
just nothing's gonna happen is just
wasted energy
toes are just gonna hurt please socks up
and sometimes you got to just get out
there get your hands dirty I think
something shoes up and it's a new saying
I'm having it okay and get on with it
but other times if you've got if you've
got a bit of savings sometimes it's
better to get better in the early days
what I would say is only get someone to
do something if they do it better than
you yeah yeah bang on yeah this actually
goes back to Brad's question
thousand-pound what would you do with it
would you recommend he invested that and
things that get in a website up and
running I'm getting all things in place
like investment in some other stuff yeah
yeah you know a thousand pounds a lot to
get a business started in it you don't
need loads of money to get like for
instance if you're looking to build on
it rocking a little bit enough to become
deal source and compliance March yeah so
could be soon to use for Brad
okay guys hope that was helpful we will
be answering more questions next week
and I think that is Eva we're back 7
o'clock next Saturday see you there see
you guys
[Applause]
you